from the moment you kind of rapped on
Breaking Bad did you always know that
you wanted to return to Jessie you know
I thought it was such a great goodbye
and so I thought if I ever return to
Jessie it may be an episode of better
call Saul but I am obsessed with that
show and I kept thinking to myself you
know when there's no there's no way that
Jessie would fit into this story and the
flash-forwards
it would make zero sense for him to show
up there and then and the the real time
frame just it's just P odd maybe in
middle school or you know it's just did
it wouldn't make sense so I really
didn't think that I would be playing
this guy again police officers calling
the level of carnage quote staggering
apparently a remote-controlled machine
gun was used in the killings
investigators are searching for a person
of interest who fled the scene anyone
with information
this massacre is asked to call police
immediately so when it started so coming
together the film did you kind of have
any doubts hesitation zero you know I
trust Vince with my life I really do and
he gave me a career he's such an
incredible storyteller and so I always
say look if you trusted Vince and the
entirety of Breaking Bad then you should
trust him with El Camino I mean he did
such a beautiful job with the show and
such a beautiful job with this film you
know he approached you with such care
you know when he floated the idea to me
he told me he's like look this isn't 100
percent can happen I just want to make
sure that you were on board before I
started writing but he's like let me
write it and if it's not great then we
won't do it but if it's perfect then
we'll move forward and and here we are
and how was it fee because of course I
mean as funds of the show we've all
speculated and thought about you know
what might have happened to Jesse when
you kind of got that script or Vince
explained what was going to happen did
you kind of aspiration us as I was in
terms of like I need to know I need to
know yeah yeah I mean I kept checking in
Vince how's it going you know and he
would send me a screenshot of just a
couple lines and like I had noticed like
what page he was on you know slowly but
surely he he completed it and I I was I
was desperate to know what what happened
you know
I always thought that he actually would
find his way to Alaska for some reason
when people asked me where do you think
Jesse went when the show ended I would
say you know in a perfect world I would
think he would find his way to Alaska
he's gonna be in hiding you know his
fingerprints are all over that meth lab
all over that crime scene so he's gonna
be constantly looking over his shoulder
for the rest of his life but I think
he's moving in the right direction we
say in the film I was in the series you
know Jesse goes to some really dark
places how how do you kind of find that
within you having not gone through those
experiences yourself yeah you know what
uh in a way I feel like I've kind of
gone through those experiences just
through Jesse Pinkman I as an actor I
don't try to pull from personal
experiences I just try to force myself
to believe that these situations are
happening as the character and just
through my career a lot of trial and
error but this guy is just gone through
such turmoil he's really been just
dragged through the mud and so to tap
into that sort of darkness and that pain
for me was incredibly easy and now we've
seen Jesse's ending and and it's kind of
my supposed the end of the road in a
sense say you kind of ready to leave the
character behind and move on so yeah
yeah I mean I was ready to say goodbye
to this guy so long ago but you know
here we are doing a movie but yeah I
think this was a the purpose of this
film was to give Jesse and the audience
a proper goodbye and we did just that
and so I think this is a goodbye
how strange was it filming effectively
like a big chunk of Breaking Bad an
extra but without Brian it was great
no no it was it was beautiful you know I
was surrounded by so many of our same
crew members that we had when we shot
the pilot of Breaking Bad so it was so
nice to you know the exact same prop
Department handing me you know my gun or
my money or it's just it's it was going
home you know with break with Jesse
Pinkman it was revisiting an old sort of
kind of tortured friend in a way and it
was great and it was but that's seen
with Brian towards the end of the film
and also towards the end of the shoot it
was just something to really look
forward to and it was great you ready